Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Tonight,
inshalla,
we want to read a narration
that works into what we left off on a
couple of weeks ago before our break.
And it has to do with
the arrival, the emergence of a
and our prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us in this particular
narration one of his descriptions.
Now this description is both literal and
metaphorical.
It is to be understood literally and it
is also to be understood figuratively.
And as we mentioned before, the
emergence of
the
the man that will emerge. He has one of
his two eyes is damaged. That young man
that will emerge.
This is a culmination of a particular
environment, attitude, disposition that
will be widespread on the earth for
hundreds of years in the making. Right?
He will not just emerge as a fish out of
water. He will emerge as the climax or
the peak of this attitude when it
becomes widespread. and that is
selfishness,
godlessness,
debauchery,
decadence. These are all the types of
words that come to mind
when describing
but also describing the fitna of al-
and the fitna of al-
does not necessitate that a be
physically present or having had emerged
in order for that fitna to be present.
That fitna will intensify and intensify
and intensify and will finally culminate
with the emergence of the
personification
of a digit. But prior to that there will
be an environment that will slowly
turn towards this this peak or
this this happening.
I'm sorry.
for
[Silence]
me.
foreign.
[Silence]
So this narration here is actually on
the authority of Hifa.
said inahkari
people used to always ask the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam about good things.
They would ask him about good deeds and
the way to access the gates of paradise.
However, I used to most frequently ask
him about bad things because I was
afraid that I might fall into these bad
things, that I might be scooped up by
these bad things unbeknownst. So we see
that many narrations that have to do
with the end times that have to do with
that have to do with certain fiten or
certain chaotic instances
that the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam prophesized we'll see that is
the narrator because he almost
specialized if you will in these types
of narrations.
So
very very famous
narrator of hadith. He's one of the
he has two other brothers. So we have
we have one of his brothers
spoke after death and he was actually
one of the miracles of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. Isa said
a man, she narrates that we used to
share with one another the companions
that a man from this ummah will speak
after his death and this ended up being
the brother of
he's one of the when he actually passed
away
the person came to bathe him and he was
laid out on the table and he actually
opened his eyes, smiled at him and said,
"Wash me quickly. I have a meeting with
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam." I
mean, this is
horrifying as it is wholesome, right?
So I'm sure that that person that
that bathed this man had an interesting
night you know that that evening. But
these are three brothers that are
considered to be one of the they are
royalty from amongst the
their narrations are found in all six
books of hadith.
He says, "I went in the company of Abui
to visit."
And so Abu Mas said to
So Abu said,
"Narrate to us. Tell us something that
you heard from the messenger of Allah
S.ai Wasallam regarding the
and so saidchech.
[Silence]
forch.
So listen to this narration here. We
have three men.
We have Abu Badri and we have
and as they're visiting
Abu
he says to tell us something that you
heard from the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam regarding a dj.
He said the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said that a gel will emerge.
And one of his most prominent hallmarks
is that when a gel emerges, he will have
with him a fire and a water. In other
narrations, a river of fire and a river
of water.
He says, "And that fire
in reality appears to be fire, but it is
actually cool and quenching water."
And that water that appears to be water
is actually a burning fire. And so if
any of you is facing a dead, we are told
that if we hear of a ded's emergence,
what are we supposed to do? First thing
we do,
what is the first thing we do?
[Arabic recitation]
However, our prophet tells us that if
you find yourself having to face him,
then you are to put yourself in his fire
because what people see to that appears
to be fire is actually a cool and
quenching water. This narration is in
Bkari Muslim. Now imagine this. We said
that this is both literal and
metaphorical. This is to both be
taken literally and figuratively.
So what does that mean to us?
Do you trust the prophet sallallahu
alaii wasallam more than you trust your
own eyes and ears? Because that's what
this takes,
right? This is not something that just a
person has at that moment.
You have to trust him and trust the
Quran, trust the prophet sallallah.aii
more than you trust your own eyes and
ears.
This fire that will accompany him, it's
not just a fire you would see on a
TV screen. It's not just a holograph. It
is, it smells fire. It behaves like
fire. It feels fire. It smells like
fire. When you get close to it, it
intensifies,
you will see what appears to be people
being drowned and burned in this fire,
right? And vice versa for the water.
People that you see that will go into
this water, it will appear as though
they are enjoying it. It will appear as
though they are drinking this beautiful
quenching water, but in reality they are
being burned to death.
And so in order for you to pass this
fitna of a dead,
don't hang around. Don't listen to his
words.
You are supposed to go to that fire and
leap into it. and one narration stick
your head into it and another to jump
into it.
I mean that that's a lot of trust
that a person is to have and that is the
kind of trust that is demanded of the
Muslim in the latter days of this dunya.
It's not going to be enough to just
casually trust the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam or to embrace the sunnah
when it suits a person rather during
these times of a you have to actively go
against the grain. You have to actively
bely your own ears, your own eyes, your
own touch, smell, taste. You have to not
trust anyone else. You have to be that
one off
that is so certain of what the prophet
said that even when your eyes and ears
and body scream the opposite, you are
willing to mistrust even your own body
and your own senses in order to be saved
from this fitna of
now that of course is with a and that is
literal. He literally has these two
things. But as well that is also to be
taken figuratively right in our time
today. Is there not a kind of figurative
river of fire and river of water?
Is it not that every billboard and
commercial sells you that river of
water? Is it not that it is intruding
into your home, brainwashing your
children, brainwashing you and your wife
and your family members, causing you to
be lulled to sleep. You know it's wrong.
You know you should reject it, but it
just feels so good.
The comfort and the pleasure is to an
extent that the door to the prison is
open but nobody's leaving because it
feels too good.
And that's what it is going to take for
a person to be able to trust and be able
to embrace the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam's words and teachings
and way and this is how our prophet
tells us that at the end of time holding
on to your religion will be akin to what
huh holding on to
holding on to burning embers that is how
that is how it will be for those holding
to their religion at the end of time
well why is that because that river of
water is sweeping us away, right? We
know that it is wrong. We know that it
will end up burning us, but we can't
help it. It's just too comfortable. The
pillow is too soft for us to wake up.
And this is what we are faced with as we
grow nearer and nearer and nearer to the
emergence of
[Silence]
Subhan Allah.
All sub.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
How are you?
[Silence]
Yeah. So,
We're not awesome.